>>> BEIJING IS FACING ITS WORST
COVID OUTBREAK AFTER THE
GOVERNMENT EASED STRICT
CONTAINMENT MEASURES NEARLY TWO
WEEKS AGO.
WHAT'S SURPRISING IS THE
GOVERNMENT ISN'T REPORTING MANY
DEATHS, YET AT THE SAME TIME THE
DEATH BUSINESS SEEMS TO BE
SURGING.
HERE'S CNN'S SALINA WANG
REPORTING FROM BEIJING.
>> Reporter: CHINA HAS ONLY
REPORTED A FEW COVID DEATHS
SINCE ABANDONING ITS ZERO COVID
POLICY, BUT WHAT WE SEE ON THE
GROUND TELLS A DIFFERENT STORY.
>> THERE IS A LONG LINE OF CARS
THAT SNAKES ACROSS THIS ENTIRE
AREA OF CARS WAITING TO GET INTO
THAT CREMATION AREA.
AND IN THE PARKING LOT RIGHT NOW
IT'S COMPLETELY FULL OF CARS.
I'M SPEAKING HERE BECAUSE THERE
ARE MANY, MANY SECURITY GUARDS
PATROLLING THIS ENTIRE AREA.
AND I SPOKE TO A MAN EARLIER WHO
SAID THAT HIS CLOSE FRIEND
PASSED AWAY FROM A FEVER, THAT
THE HOSPITAL DIDN'T SAY WHY.
HE SAID HE'S BEEN WAITING HERE
FOR HOURS, AND HE STILL HAS NO
IDEA IF HIS FRIEND'S BODY CAN
EVEN GET CREMATED TODAY.
AND IT'S NOT JUST IN BEIJING.
SOCIAL MEDIA SHOWS CREMATORIUMS
AND FUNERAL HOMES AROUND THE
COUNTRY OVERWHELMED.
IN THIS FUNERAL HOME THE MAN IS
SAYING IT'S GOING INSANE.
HERE IT IS PACKED WITH CARS, AND
VANS CARRYING BODIES STRETCH ALL
THE WAY INTO THE DISTANCE IN
FRONT OF THIS CREMATORIUM, AND
FAMILIES WAIT AND STAND IN THEIR
MOURNING CLOTHES AT THIS FUNERAL
HOME WITH NO IDEA HOW LONG THEY
HAVE TO WAIT BEFORE THEIR
BELOVED ONES CAN BE CREMATED.
A NEW STUDY BY HONG KONG
RESEARCHERS ESTIMATES NEARLY 1
MILLION PEOPLE IN CHINA COULD
DIE FROM COVID IF THE COUNTRY
DOESN'T TAKE NECESSARY PUBLIC
HEALTH MEASURES LIKE INCREASED
VACCINATIONS.
LONG LINES LIKE THESE ARE
FORMING ACROSS THE COUNTRY
OUTSIDE OF HOSPITALS.
PEOPLE WAIT FOR HOURS OUTSIDE IN
THE COLD RAIN, CROWDS FORM
OUTSIDE HOSPITALS IN WUHAN,
GROUND ZERO OF THE ORIGINAL
OUTBREAK.
THIS IS A COVID OUTBREAK
HOSPITAL IPBEIJING.
THERE'S BEEN A STEADY STREAM OF
ELDERLY PATIENTS IN WHEELCHAIRS
BEING LED INTO THIS HOSPITAL.
I SPOKE TO AN MAWHO WAS WAITING
OUTSIDE FOR HIS ELDERLY FAMILY
MEMBER WHO HE SAYS IS VERY SICK
WITH A HIGH FEVER FROM COVID,
BUT HE SAYS THIS HOSPITAL IS
RUNNING OUT OF BED SPACE.
ARE YOU BUSY I ASK THE COVID
WORKER OUTSIDE THIS HOSPITAL.
YES, EXTREMELY BUSY, HE TELLS
ME.
WE EVEN WORK INTO THE EVENINGS.
DID A LOT OF PEOPLE DIE HERE, I
ASK.
YES, EVERY DAY, HE SAYS.
IS IT ALL BECAUSE OF COVID?
YES, HE SAYS, PEOPLE WITH
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS.
THE COUNTRY'S COVID STRATEGY HAS
SUDDENLY SWUNG FROM ONE EXTREME
TO ANOTHER.
THIS IS WHAT CHINA'S METROPOLIS
LOOKED LIKE A MONTH AGO DURING A
MASS COVID LOCKDOWN, A GHOST
CITY.
BUT NOW NOT ONLY HAS IT LIFTED
ITS LOCK DOWN, THE GOVERNMENT
ANNOUNCED ON PRIME TIME
TELEVISION THAT PEOPLE WHO HAVE
COVID AS LONG AS THEY'RE ONLY
MILDLY SICK OR A SYMPTOMATIC,
WELL, THEY CAN RETURN TO WORK.
BUT PEOPLE ARE STILL SCARED TO
GO OUT.
RESTAURANTS AND SHOPPING MALLS
IN THE CITY BARELY HAVE ANY
CUSTOMERS.
SUBWAYS ACROSS MAJOR CITIES ARE
EERILY EMPTY, BUT NONE OF THIS
IS STOPPING CHINESE STATE MEDIA
AS HAILING THE COUNTRY'S COVID
STRATEGY AS VICTORY AFTER
VICTORY AS THE CHINESE PEOPLE
FEEL THEY ARE SUDDENLY LEFT TO
FEND FOR THEMSELVES.
AND, JOHN, IF WE'RE ALREADY
SEEING THIS MAJOR STRAIN ON THE
HOSPITAL SYSTEM IN BEIJING, THE
CAPITOL OF CHINA THAT'S
WELL-RESOURCED, WELL, YOU CAN
IMAGINE THE DEVASTATION WE MIGHT
SEE IN OTHER PARTS OF CHINA.
THE COUNTRY'S CHIEF
EPIDEMIOLOGISTS SAID THE WORST
IS STILL YET TO COME AND THE
COUNTRY IS GOING THROUGH THE
FIRST OF THREE EXPECTED WAVES.
THAT SECOND WAVE IS EXPECTED
TODAY BE TRIGGERED BY THE MASS
TRAVEL AHEAD OF THE LU